I got to fly today dude I hate here's
who I don't like on the plane okay be a
better air buddy don't be this person
the person that keeps their freaking
window open when everybody else window
is
closed how you going to keep your
window open what are you looking
at you at 30 37 you're at 37,000 feet
what you peeking around at
you peeping air time you looking
at Cloud tops what are you doing you
you trying to buy a Care Bear
what are you looking for close your dang
window because the light is coming in
and it's ruin everybody else's air
experience everybody trying to
rest you know you got this guy usually
there's like an Asian guy he sleeps like
this he makes his own you know you got
that you know you have a kind of a Ruben
kind of black lady and she just she got
on five of those you know those sultry
silky face Shades you
know you got the old white guy and
he he got his mouth
just you know you got a child and they
beating a drum both their
parents unconscious and they somebody
gave a child a drum on a plane
what the you know when a child gets
a drum never
bro never except when they in the when
they in the war and they got to send a
little child out there with a drum and
that child gets popped off you know what
I'm saying but that's you know that's
the sacrifice that they make you know
one love but you don't ever give a child
a drum you
idiot and then everybody trying to get
their rest even the pilots up there
resting you know they got co-pilots so
they you know they resting on each other
the two of them everybody's sleeping the
cart lady she coming down he's
sleeping you know the cart guy he's he's
sleeping everybody resting and then one
got to leave their window
up and that ruins everybody know
how to do air travel shut your window
you freaking mutant act regular
and watch your life change for the
better you know what I'm talking about
praise God hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two
options watch one this one or this
one